This guy's probably fought hundreds of
thousands of other super beings on the
other planets he's destroyed right and
we have to assume he's won i don't care
how many demons he's fought and how many
hells he's never fought us not us united
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new justice league snyder cut trailer
video they just posted a new one there's some
new scenes that they worked in obviously it's
black and white i'll explain what's going on with
that so if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll do a new
amazon giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know what your favorite
easter egg is from the trailer zack snyder
actually did a lot of commentary for this this
morning himself he's actually been going on a lot
of podcasts recently talking about the movie what
his plans are i think he's done at least three
different fan podcasts he probably has the best
relationship of any big director of big studio
films with his fandom so it is really cool to see
him interacting with fans in that big way and he
did say that they have big plans for a special
marketing campaign when they actually release
the snyder cut on hbo max next year but the reason
why they released this new version of the trailer
in black and white today november 17th is because
it's the anniversary of the release of the justice
league theatrical cut the reason why it's black
and white is because zack snyder said that he
wanted to release a black and white version of
the movie theatrically but i think he said that he
fought with the studio on that like they were not
too hot on the idea of releasing a black and white
version of a movie this big you may remember that
they did the exact same thing for hugh jackman's
logan movie for that last wolverine movie they
let james mangold add a black and white cut of
the movie to the blu-ray release but i don't
think they wound up releasing that theatrically
so there is precedent for them doing black and
white cuts of movies that were actually shot in
color before zack snyder also said that he would
like to do a limited theatrical release so i'll
explain that in a second too particularly in imax
release just because of the way he shot the movie
but there is the chance that they release two
different versions of this on hbo max next year
they also kind of did that with the simpsons
episodes on disney plus where you have the
4x3 aspect ratio but you also have the widescreen
zoom version but you have to switch between those
manually in the settings menu so it's not like
it's impossible to release two different cuts of
a movie on these platforms but one of the first
new scenes here is the scene of superman taking
flight just as part of this scene that we've
seen of ben affleck's batman staring up at his
boots there were always lots of theories about
what he was looking at here most people thought
it was superman some people even thought that it
might be super girl i think because zack snyder in
the past had talked about a version of supergirl
existing within the universe and sort of teasing
the idea that she might appear someday but because
we get the full version of this scene now you can
actually see what's happening here it's just
cyborg projecting a version of superman taking
flight as they're standing around talking about
him before he's come back to life because they're
all standing around in their street clothes so
this is just a slightly different version of one
of these scenes here really early in the movie
the way zack snyder talked about it none of the
scenes in his version of the movie will look
at all like the scenes from the theatrical cut
but talking a little bit more about the aspect
ratio notice in this aquaman scene here around
the edges of the frame for a little bit here they
actually go rounded and then go back to square
that's just an effect of the lens while they were
filming these scenes and i'm assuming that because
these are the official trailers it might wind
up looking like this during the movie itself
but he's still in the middle of post-production
so we'll have to wait till they release some
more trailers to see what changes between this
trailer and those trailers i think back when they
made batman be superman i remember some of the
earlier trailers looked a little bit different
just because the clips they were using weren't
completely done when they were releasing those
trailers but the actual reason why this trailer
is square 4x3 looking aspect ratio is because
that's the aspect ratio that he shot the movie in
really it's meant to be imac's aspect ratio true
imax with the giant square screens the really huge
ones he said that he just fell in love with that
style when he was working on the imax portions of
batman v superman so eventually when it came time
to film justice league he just decided to do the
entire movie like that but when joss whedon came
on the project the studio decided to release a
16x9 aspect ratio version so you have to imagine
them just zooming in on a lot of the footage that
zack snyder filmed but when you do that you wind
up losing a lot of the footage at the bottom and
the tops of the frames there's a whole bunch of
new cyborg scenes in this version of the trailer
there's a new scene of cyborg in his apartment
earlier in the movie watching kids playing
football in the street just remembering what
his life was like before the accident before he
became cyborg that's why right before this scene
in the trailer they show you him playing football
at gotham university with his mom cheering him in
the crowd i believe that they've also posted
some previews of the other scene of him and
his mother in the car before their big accident
i think his mother's supposed to have a death
scene during the movie as part of his origin story
and most of you have probably seen at least some
version of cyborg's origin story in the comics
or the animated series or the animated movies
they're all relatively similar his father runs
star labs but he's too busy to be a really good
dad too engrossed in his work there's an accident
and it's only by fusing cyborg with the mother box
that allows him to survive but the way they treat
that story and some of the more recent versions
like especially young justice is a bit more like a
horror story like he briefly loses his mind as the
mother box tech or father box tech in the case
of young justice starts reprogramming his mind
until he's able to assert his own dominance over
it there was a little bit of that story during the
justice league theatrical cut where the mother box
tech just automatically responds to the threat of
superman with hostility just arming up a bunch of
weapons some of the motherbox cannon made it into
the theatrical cut for instance we know stefan
both is going to look very different way more
hardcore but remember in the theatrical cup when
he kept talking about the unity and talking to
the mother boxes like they were a person calling
them mother that's because originally according
to some of the changes that people talked
about in the theatrical cut the life force of
steppenwolf's mother hegra was actually supposed
to be trapped inside the three mother boxes
and by combining them creating the quote-unquote
unity that he kept talking about in the movie he'd
be able to reunite the pieces of her and use her
true power but for instance during his commentary
zack snyder talked about darkseid combining the
mother boxes to create the unity and unleash the
anti-life equation so even though there have been
a bunch of retcons in the comics and the way they
explain where the anti-life equation comes from
and what it's all about it sounds like dark side
is using the mother boxes in combination with the
anti-life equation the omega force is a little bit
different though darkseid actually stole that from
his older brother he sort of usurped the throne
of apocalypse taking the omega force that's what
gives him the omega beams his near invincibility
that's where the omega symbol in his chest comes
from the omega symbol that's burned into the
ground he just starts using that as his branding
symbol this is another new scene of batman in the
batmobile from the final battle taking out some
parademons intercut with another new scene of
hippolyta fighting what looks like steppenwolf and
the parademons inside their temple of themyscira
where they kept the motherbox i'm assuming in
the snyder cut version of the movie even though
the movie's supposed to be over four hours long
this scene of steppenwolf coming to earth still
happens relatively early in the film this scene
of the flash running around mid air seems kind
of like a prelude to him using the speed force
to time travel or maybe a multiverse easter egg
just the way it seems so different from how they
visualize his regular running ability way back at
dc fandom zack snyder was hyping up new abilities
quote unquote that the flash would have that we
haven't seen before with patty jenkins and made
it sound like he'd be doing some time traveling
or some multiverse easter eggs just as a prelude
to the flash flashpoint movie the other brand new
thing from the past week that a lot of you are
messaging me about was all the martian manhunter
teasing that zack snyder was doing during one of
those he flashed this concept dart and picture
of harry lennox's martian manhunter separately
harry lennox himself has also been hyping it up
so i don't know which part of the movie this is
supposed to fit into and i don't know if he always
intended it to be this way but now it seems like
it's official like he wouldn't be posting this if
he didn't intend to pay it off at some point i
haven't seen him talk much more about the green
lantern stuff in the movie recently i think he's
still holding most of that close to the vest i've
talked a little bit about the original plans for
post-credit scenes with green lanterns but those
weren't meant to be hal jordan green lanterns
it was just meant to be killwog and tomar ray
as far as i know zack snyder isn't going
to be involved in the green lantern hbo
series or the new green lantern corps movie that
they're still planning on making at some point
but now whatever happens with green lantern stuff
in the movie it seems like it'll be contained to
what zack snyder is calling the snyder vs movies
the movies that he made inside the dceu and i
think what they'll do is is once they do these
new movies they'll use the flash flashpoint movie
in the idea of the multiverse the dc multiverse
to sort of connect everything so that it all
eventually makes sense even though it seems a
little complicated right now the way that andy
muschietti explained it the director of the flash
movie is that they're going to use the multiverse
to explain how everything from the comics the
classic movies like christopher reeves superman
michael keaton's batman can be connected to the
newer dc movies and the dceu movies that zack
snyder made it's the exact same thing that they
did with spider-man into the spider-verse getting
really meta with the way it tried to canonize
everything from all the previous versions of
spider-man movies tv shows and comics even the
animated stuff like spider-pig zack snyder also
did clarify what was going on with future dc
projects he said that he did have a script for
justice league two but just a couple days ago he
clarified that he says he never expects that he'll
be able to make that which i think also means that
the batman dark knight returns frank miller movie
that he also talked about making probably won't
wind up happening anytime soon i think short term
if the justice league snyder cut goes really well
for them then there is always the chance that he
does another hbo max series with some other
ip that might not necessarily be dc comics ip
and as for wonder woman 1984 originally they
were going to release the movie on christmas but
because we're heading into what seems like another
lockdown around the world deadline was reporting
that right now warner brothers is thinking about
releasing it on hbo max around christmas day but
simultaneously releasing it in theaters some
places around the world where theaters are
still open the other option is for them to just
delay the movie to the summer so you guys can
let me know in the comments whether or not you'd
rather just have them release it on hbo max and in
some theater simultaneously around christmas or
just wait to the middle of next year to see it
what's going to happen is i have a couple other
mandalorian season two videos that i'm going to
make this week for bo katan the darksaber my
mandalorian season 2 episode 4 video we'll post
on friday there'll probably be some more dc
videos and marvel so leave all your requests
in the comments below while you wait for
everything click here for my full mandalorian
season 2 episode 3 video and click here for my
brand new mandalorian season 2 ahsoka tano video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!